[Música]
en Estados Unidos ron de santis presentó
oficialmente su candidatura a las
primarias del partido republicano con
una ofensiva radical antiderechos en
Florida el gobernador se presenta como
alternativa al expresidente Donald Trump
Tenemos reporte desde Washington
en Ecuador el presidente Guillermo lasso
rindió cuentas de su mandato
presidencial en un escenario distinto a
la sede del parlamento disuelto por el
decreto de muerte Cruzada el Consejo
Nacional electoral ya confirmó el 20 de
agosto como la nueva fecha para las
elecciones anticipadas
la leyenda de la música Tina Turner
falleció este miércoles a los 83 años en
su casa de Suiza tras dejar una huella
incomparable en la historia de la
cultura pop ampliamos desde Nueva York
Buenas tardes Bienvenidos a las noticias
de France 24 en español Soy Rosa Pérez
Mateo y es para mí un gusto acompañarles
abrimos esta edición en Estados Unidos
porque el gobernador de Florida ron de
santis presentó ya los documentos que
oficializan su candidatura para las
primarias del partido republicano el
ultraconservador se suma así a una
carrera protagonizada de momento por el
expresidente Donald Trump nuestro
corresponsal en Washington Cristóbal
Vázquez nos amplía
sobre todo el electorado de la Florida
donde recordemos fue reelecto en las
últimas elecciones al estado por Más de
19 puntos donde santis tiene 44 años
educó en la universidad de Yellow y de
Harvard en leyes después fue congresista
por Orlando un Distrito electoral
cercano a la ciudad de Orlando en la
Florida y siendo congresista fundó el
caucus de la extrema derecha en Estados
Unidos sus políticas son radicales y muy
polémicas en cuanto a inmigración en
cuanto al aborto y en cuanto a políticas
de género Precisamente en cuanto a
inmigración ha habido muchas críticas
recientes porque sus políticas radicales
frente a este tema han hecho que muchos
inmigrantes indocumentados se vayan del
estado y esto ha hecho que la el negocio
de la propiedad raíz y la construcción
pues se haya encarecido y ha recibido
varias críticas al respecto Ron llega
entonces a la carrera presidencial como
el principal contrincante de Donald
Trump Donald Trump de hecho ya reaccionó
en redes sociales atacando al
precandidato presidencial de la Florida
diciendo que no tiene personalidad que
es un discípulo de otro congresista
llamado y que que simplemente no es un
republicano de pura cepa además hay que
Resaltar también que en las últimas
encuestas Donald Trump va por encima en
cuanto a intención de voto de los
republicanos y el segundo que le sigue
es precisamente
continuamos en Estados Unidos que sigue
en vilo a una semana de que según el
departamento del tesoro el país entra en
situación de impagos Y es que tras
varias reuniones republicanos y
demócratas no logran un acuerdo para
aumentar el límite del techo de la deuda
dadas las grandes discrepancias sobre
cómo gestionar el gasto público sin
embargo el presidente de la cámara de
representantes el republicano Kevin
mccarthy declaró que las conversaciones
con la Casa Blanca continúan
enviaré a nuestro equipo de negociación
a la casa blanca hoy para tratar de
terminar las negociaciones con la Casa
Blanca hay varios lugares en los que
todavía estamos muy separados quiero
decir no pareciera que fuera a ser así
de difícil
Bueno antes que nada Permítame decirle
al público estadounidense que no me voy
a rendir no vamos a incumplir vamos a
resolver este problema me quedaré con él
Hasta que podamos hacerlo pero seamos
honestos sobre esto tenemos que gastar
menos de lo que gastamos el año pasado
no es mi culpa que los demócratas no
puedan renunciar a sus gastos
en otras noticias de Estados Unidos Hoy
hace un año del tiroteo en una escuela
de en una escuela de ubal de Texas en
que un hombre armado mató a 19 niños y a
dos adultos y a esta hora avanza la
investigación sobre la tardía respuesta
policial mientras las propuestas
legislativas de restringir el porte de
armas continúan bloqueadas
la tragedia de la escuela primaria Duval
de cumple un año el 24 de mayo de 2022
un tirador de 18 años irrumpió en la
primaria rock y protagonizó un ataque
que duró 77 minutos
19 niños y dos maestros murieron las
heridas siguen frescas para la comunidad
de esta localidad de Texas como es el
caso de Verónica mata madre de Test una
de las niñas asesinadas
tenemos que aprender a revivir nuestras
vidas
porque nuestras vidas no son las mismas
y nuestras vidas nunca serán las mismas
Entonces siempre falta esa pieza
Sabes quiero decir
realmente no hay nada que pueda detener
lo que estoy sintiendo A menos que
puedan traerla de vuelta pero no pueden
hacer eso
en paralelo continúan las
investigaciones sobre el crimen y la
deficiente respuesta de la policía que
demora en intervenir y luego dio
versiones contradictorias para
justificar su accionar
esta semana es una semana difícil ni
siquiera podemos imaginar el dolor que
las familias están sintiendo un año y
nos damos cuenta de que todavía no
tienen las respuestas que necesitan y
eso nos ha frustrado a todos pido
disculpas el gobierno de Estados Unidos
incita en la necesidad de leyes que
restrinjan la posesión de armas mientras
eso parece un objetivo lejano las armas
de fuego son la principal causa de
muerte de niños y adolescentes solo en
2022 se registraron más de 300
incidentes en instituciones educativas
causando al menos 270 muertes mientras
en 2023 ya hubo por lo menos 33 hechos
de esta clase
vamos ahora a Ecuador porque en medio de
la crisis política el presidente
Guillermo lasso rindió cuentas de su
último año en la presidencia en un
auditorio de quito la capital del país
un acontecimiento que normalmente tiene
lugar en la sede del parlamento pero
este año la ubicación cambió debido al
decreto de muerte Cruzada con el que el
mandatario disolvió la asamblea nacional
y desató elecciones anticipadas de hecho
el Consejo Nacional electoral ya
confirmó la fecha de los comicios en el
país nuestro enviado especial Rodrigo
sedano nos amplía justo del comienzo de
este discurso de Guillermo lasso hemos
podido hablar con la presidenta del cne
que nos ha confirmado a la cámara y al
micrófono de France 24 que el 20 de
agosto será la fecha para esas
elecciones también esta noche habrá una
locución a la nación donde se terminará
de confirmar esa fecha como repito 20 de
agosto fecha de las elecciones y de unas
consultas populares también sobre
explotaciones petrolíferas y minerales
en unos parques nacionales del país
ahora espera una carrera presidencial
con mucho ajetreo y en la que los
partidos tendrán realmente poco tiempo
para presentar a esos candidatos y para
preparar Esta carrera presidencial en la
que como decía el 20 de agosto van a
votar de nuevo los Ecuatorianos vamos
con información de la guerra en Ucrania
porque el líder del grupo Wagner declaró
que 20.000 de sus mercenarios han muerto
en la batalla de backmud de los cuales
Diez mil eran convictos reclutados en
las cárceles rusas en otras noticias de
la guerra este miércoles Rusia denunció
un ataque masivo con drones en la región
de velgorot fronteriza con Ucrania una
ofensiva que Moscú atribuye a kiev
recordemos que la misma zona fue
escenario de una incursión el pasado
lunes reivindicada por milicias
ultraderechistas formadas por ciudadanos
rusos Opuestos a Vladimir Putin y que
vinculados con la legión extranjera
luchan a favor de Ucrania en esta guerra
porque estas milicias conocidas como
legión libertad de Rusia y cuerpo de
voluntarios rusos citaron a la prensa en
sumi en el norte de Ucrania y nuestra
enviada especial Catalina Gómez Ángel
estuvo allí y habló con miembros de
estos grupos que le aseguraron que kiev
estaba al corriente de sus planes de
atacar belgot ampliamos en el siguiente
informe
son dos las unidades que reivindicaron
la incursión armada en la región rusa de
velgorot una la legión libertad de Rusia
incluye a militares desertores y la otra
es el cuerpo de voluntarios rusos de
extrema derecha fundado por Denis
nikitin un neonazi que ha vivido en
Alemania ambos están comprometidos con
el derrocamiento del gobierno de
Vladimir Putin kiev declaró que no
estaba implicada en el ataque de
belgorón pero expertos en seguridad
creen que las autoridades ucranianas
tienen vínculos con estos grupos
Insurgentes tenemos que darnos cuenta de
que no se trata de fuerzas
independientes Aunque la reivindicación
sea la de seguir diciendo que esto no
tiene nada que ver con nosotros que se
trata solo de voluntarios rusos están
controlados por la inteligencia militar
ucraniana imágenes de la televisión
Estatal o rusa mostraron vehículos
militares de fabricación estadounidense
supuestamente distribuidos durante la
incursión pero Estados Unidos se mostró
evasivo las preguntas sobre la
implicación de material militar
estadounidense
diré que en este momento somos
escépticos sobre la veracidad de estos
informes como principio general como
hemos dicho y creo que dije ayer no
alentamos ni permitimos ataques dentro
de Rusia y lo hemos dejado Claro
pero como también hemos dicho
corresponde a Ucrania decidir Cómo
llevar a cabo esta guerra Durante los 15
meses de guerra ya ha habido incursiones
de drones en territorios rusos pero
nunca a tal escala esto abre la
posibilidad de que Moscú tenga que
luchar en un segundo frente antes de la
contraofensiva de Ucrania esperada desde
hace tiempo y cambiamos de información
porque en España los insultos racistas
contra el delantero del Real Madrid
vinicius Junior han vuelto a poner sobre
la mesa El problema del racismo en el
país tanto dentro como fuera de los
campos de fútbol nuestra corresponsal
Marina Colorado habló con los
aficionados que fueron al derbi entre el
real Madrid y el Rayo Vallecano y habló
con ellos sobre las medidas que debería
tomar el mundo del deporte español
el Real Madrid volvió a pisar el césped
tras el partido contra el Valencia del
domingo que desató un huracán de
reacciones y debates sobre el racismo en
el fútbol dentro y fuera de España lo
hizo sin vinicius Junior víctima de los
recientes ataques racistas que fue baja
por unas molestias en la rodilla antes
de que empezara el derbi contra el Rayo
Vallecano la afición opinaba sobre el
tema es algo que predomina mucho en el
fútbol los insultos tanto de racismo
como de xenofobia de todo tipo y es algo
que no tendría que tener cabida en el
fútbol no se puede permitir eso en
ningún campo de fútbol da igual que sea
aquí en vallecas el Camp Nou de igual
aquí no creo tener eso consiste un poco
animal a tu equipo y ya está disfrutar
lo que al final Pues mira no le están
insultando porque ser racista España no
es un país racista está insultando
porque es un jugador del otro equipo le
desconcentra le sacan del partido juega
mal pues ganan la gana la partida
Mientras que el martes hubo varios
detenidos y el Valencia recibió una
multa de 45.000 euros y se cerró
temporalmente la grada del mes talla en
la que se dieron los insultos en España
prima la impunidad ante estos actos
nunca se ha suspendido un partido ni ha
habido condenas Pese a que el código
penal español establece penas de hasta
dos años de cárcel en Casos de racismo o
xenofobia no se asignada para castigar
Así que parece que es un problema muy
estructural y que no ha sido resuelto Yo
creo que con la gente que está
insultando porque les corte la entrada
sería y así por la gente va aprendiendo
y no lo haría el partido no puede
continuar cuando hay estas faltas de
respeto a los jugadores sean del equipo
que sean quedan un par de jornadas en
esta recta final de la liga veremos si
este parón ayuda a tener un debate
sosegado y a implementar medidas
contundentes o si la pausa en la
competición diluye la conversación y el
problema vuelve a caer en el olvido
y cerramos con la conmoción en el mundo
de la música por la partida de Tina
Turner la estrella estadounidense del
rock y del Soul falleció este miércoles
a los 83 años en su residencia de Zurich
en Suiza con himnos tan coreados como
What love of to do it y con una estética
vanguardista la cantante se convirtió en
un ícono pop que cautivó los oídos y los
espíritus de todo el planeta previamente
nuestra corresponsal en Nueva York mamen
sala no recuerdo su figura
Así que no decir de ella compañeros aquí
se refieren a ella como La reina del
rock esa leyenda musical imparable La
historia estadounidense musical son
algunas de las referencias que están
haciendo hoy a ella una mujer que nació
hace 83 años en tennessey en los 50 se
lanzó con su hermana a cantar en clubs
nocturnos en San Luis en Missouri fue
allí precisamente donde conoció a su
esposo quien le dio el sobrenombre
artístico de Tina Turner Y a partir de
ahí todos conocéis esa historia de
éxitos encima de los escenarios que duró
hasta el 2013 año en el que decidió
retirarse lo hizo como decíais en Zurich
en Suiza allí llevaba varios años
luchando contra algunas enfermedades que
hoy pues han apagado su voz pero desde
luego no su música desde que se ha
conocido la noticia de su muerte aquí la
mayoría de las cadenas han interrumpido
su programación para explicar lo que ha
ocurrido en la radio estamos escuchando
constantemente sus grandes éxitos y en
televisión testimonios de amigos
familiares artistas que convivieron con
ella a lo largo de su vida que recuerdan
su poderosa voz su estilo artístico sin
igual su maravillosa puesta en escena
Pues todos recuerdos que desde luego se
quedarán siempre con nosotros igual que
su música porque como digo se ha pagado
ella pero desde luego no su legado
musical con este recuerdo de China
Turner llegamos al final de esta edición
pero recuerden que pueden ampliar toda
esta y más información
enseguida volvemos
[Música]